okay final question let's have a look at
this one together it's going to be
mechanics
an object of mass 80 kilograms that's
important falls from rest under
gravitational acceleration of g
and air resistance of 0.2 v
newton's v for velocity
find the velocity of the object after
time t find the limiting or the terminal
velocity of the object and find out how
far has the object fallen after time
t right so how do we go about this
question
the first thing that was problematic for
students when they were having a go out
what is this c when they were having a
go at c was that they failed to read the
question carefully
and notice that the particular forces
that are at play here have been very
very carefully described to you right so
when you say
the force is equal to mass times
acceleration
what are the accelerations in this
situation well there's going to be
the acceleration that's due to gravity
and then there's going to be an
acceleration that's due to this air
resistance right now if you just draw
again a very very simple diagram here
okay you are going to have
gravity pulling you downwards and then
you're going to have air resistance
pushing against you pushing upwards
because this is an object that is
falling from rest
now think about this right
this is an object of mass 80 kilograms
so therefore it's going to have a weight
force of 80 times gravity and um gravity
has not if the constant has been defined
as 10 or 9.8 or anything like that so
it's 80g right
what about the air resistance it's going
to be
0.2 times the velocity the faster it's
going the more air resistance it is
experiencing now when you have a look at
that i want you to look carefully right
you can see that mass is part of the
gravity the gravitational acceleration
but mass in this question is not part of
the
uh air resistance
acceleration right it's 0.2 v and this
is often the case right um often air
resistance has nothing to do with how
heavy something is it's how to do with
how big it is right um have a think
about a parachute yeah a parachute is
the same mass when it is folded up as
when it is you know released
but
even though mass its mass doesn't change
its shape changes and also its velocity
changes the faster the parachute is
going the more the parachute is slowing
you down so in this case many students
made the era of thinking ah this is
gonna this is supposed to have an m in
it as well so when they were doing this
they kind of introduced m with this um
air resistance where actually the
question very specifically states that
it does not have any m
associated with it so my forces are
going to be
um you know because it's mass times
acceleration i can say that's 80 times
the acceleration but my acceleration is
in turn
going to be equal to
and i'm going to take the two
accelerations from gravity and from air
resistance noting which one is positive
so this is a downward journey so i'm
going to call downward as positive
so that means that the atg will be
positive
and then the air resistance the 0.2 v
will be negative so i get minus 0.2 v
and i guess i can divide through to get
an acceleration equation so that just
gives me g
take away now 0.2 is 1 over 5. so
therefore you divide by 80 you're going
to get one over 400 so that gives me v
on 400. so there was the first big error
that a lot of students made and it was
tragic that it was so early on we did
award marks for students who made an
error like that and then everything else
was fine but often an error like that
meant that it was very likely you made
errors later on as well
okay this is the correct equation for
acceleration so how do i use it remember
what we're trying to find
i want the velocity of the object after
time
t and there's lots of different ways to
say acceleration we've seen this already
even just in this paper which is the
form of acceleration or which way of
expressing acceleration makes it easier
for me to get to velocity
as a function time and hopefully it's
clicking for you i need to get this in
terms of t so i'm going to write
acceleration as dv
on dt and this serves two purposes for
me number one the right hand side is in
terms of v so i can do my separation of
variables and i can integrate to get
that v out of it but secondly it's got
it with respect to t right so when i
integrate that part you're going to get
a t term out of it and then i can
rearrange and so on okay
so dv on dt is equal to g minus
g minus v on 400 but i notice actually
it's probably going to be helpful for me
because i'm about to integrate and i
also have to turn things like
reciprocals upside down and all that i'm
going to combine everything on the right
hand side into a single fraction it's
going to be a bit of a mess but that's
okay
multiply that by 400
that's a minus v from the second
fraction and that's all divided by 400
and now what i'm going to do is two
things at once i'm going to separate the
variables out and then i'm also going to
divide through or integrate through
rather by each of the respective
variables okay
uh what am i going to do well i'm
actually going to tell a lie there's one
more thing i think that would help me to
do to prepare this right i'm actually
going to take out a minus sign so that's
going to leave me with v minus 400 g
on the numerator
another occurring theme minus signs
really
you know troubled people as they were
appearing and disappearing throughout
your working the reason why this is
going to be useful is because once i
take the reciprocal of this thing this
fraction on the right hand side it's
going to be easier to integrate this
with v as a positive rather than v is a
negative as i had it there okay
all right so let's do our separation i'm
going to get all my v's on the left all
my t's on the right and then i'm going
to integrate in one hit okay so here we
go
all my v's on the right are left rather
so i'm going to go 400 over
v minus 400 g
dv there you go i've divided through by
everything on this side it's ready to go
and then i've got this minus sign still
hanging around and a dt and as promised
i'm going to integrate everything all in
one go so i've got an integral on the
left with respect to v integral on the
right with respect to t and this is not
complicated i've set this up so it's
quite nice i can say this is going to be
400 because that's just the constant
coefficient
log of v minus 400 g on the left hand
side and then minus dt integrates up
into minus t plus a constant
and
you know bewilderingly some people
forgot this was an indefinite integral
you had a constant that you had to worry
about
this was an advanced idea that i guess
we had forgotten about focusing on all
the extension 2 stuff right so there we
go i've got this expression here and i'm
going to need to find out what this
constant is
how do i do that well
if you have a look back at the question
what's over here actually you can see
that this object of mass 80 kilograms it
falls from rest so the reason why that's
important is because it gives me an
initial condition for velocity the
initial velocity must be zero that's
what falls from rest means so therefore
i can say
oops
when
t equals 0
v equals 0.
so therefore i can go ahead and i can
substitute that in on the left hand side
i'm going to get 400
log of
absolute value of minus 400
g equals i'm going to get that minus 0
there plus a constant
and at this point here i can say a
couple of things firstly it's just my
constant it's equal to 400 log and i
noticed that i used absolute values here
because i got it from this integration
process
i know what
i've got a base of e so i need a
positive base means i've got to have a
positive thing inside the log and i know
that g is going to be positive even if
it's i don't know whether it's 9.8 or
it's 10 it's something positive so
therefore i can just replace that with
400 g because that's the absolute value
of that
there's the constant so therefore i can
say
let's pop that in so 400
log of v minus 400 g equals minus t
plus
400
log
400 g
now uh from here i can then say well t
is going to be equal to and i'm going to
subtract this term across to the other
side so it's going to give me
um
and i don't know why i dropped off my
absolute value signs there it's going to
be equal to
400
i'll take that common factor out log of
and when you subtract logs 1 from
another i'm subtracting this log from
this one that's equivalent to division
right so therefore i can say that's
actually v minus 400 g
all divided by 400 g
done so there is t
as a function of v and this is a really
important point right um just making
sure i got my order right here t minus v
minus 400 oh no i tell a lie there's a
minus t there so now i'm actually going
to say t equals and i'm going to
multiply through by minus 1. so that
gives me a minus on this side i might as
well do this extra step for you
make sure i don't skip anything here
so that's that
but that
minus 1 there can actually go up and
become an index right so it actually
flips this upside down so that gives me
if i turn that positive 400 log of
that's better
this is what i get for working things
out beforehand 400 g minus
v minus 400 g that's time okay there we
go
happy now here's the thing several
students stopped at this point because
maybe they felt like man i've done a lot
of work i integrated did this diagram
and everything
and i've got like i've evaluated my
constant integration it all looks nice
the only problem is just go back to the
original question it says find the
velocity of the object after time t
that's v
as a function of t
is that what we've actually worked out
in my working over here do i have v as a
function of t and the answer is no i
have
t as a function of v it's the other way
around
this is t
as a function of v
not
v as a function of t and a lot of
students stopped at this point and just
sort of you know went on to part two
because you didn't necessarily need to
you know work out what
v is a function of t was to solve part
two even though it was in in some ways
easier
for me and this is why it's worth three
marks i need to keep going okay so what
am i going to do um i need to make v the
subject so i'm going to divide through
by 400 to get this log term by itself
that gives me all of this
and then i notice that this is
base a right so in order to turn this
log equation into something that gets
the v separated out i am going to turn
this into an e to the power of right so
therefore i can say this um
this here
which is inside the log is going to be e
to the t on 400. now i'm going to undo a
trick that i pulled before with my minus
t i'm going to flip my fraction back
upside down go v minus 400 g on 400 g
and if i've flipped the left hand side
upside down i'll flip the right hand
side upside down but it's easy to do
that with indices by just applying a
minus sign minus t
on 400
from there i guess i just multiply
through so v minus 400 g is equal to
400 g
outside of e to the negative t on 400
and then i'm going to add this to both
sides so you can see
i get v equals and you'll be careful
here by the way because
there's a
a minus sign that kind of crept out from
in here when we applied that that uh
absolute value so in fact when i came
back out here i'm going to return that
there like so um so there's a minus sign
there as well i'm going to add the 400 g
there minus 400
g e to the negative t on 400
and um just to tidy things up i will
take a factor of 400 g out just
factorize like so so it's one take away
that
okay and i'm done at last i've got v as
a function of t and that's where i can
actually stop the question
we're getting close now how do we get to
part two well what we're being asked for
here is terminal velocity and there's a
couple of different ways to do it i
think the simplest way is to say that
the terminal velocity it occurs when no
more force is acting on the
on the
particle on the object that's falling
it's an object of mass 80 kilograms
right so therefore it occurs when
there's no more acceleration
if it was still accelerating it would
not be the final or limiting velocity so
i can say it's x double dot equals 0.
and the attraction of doing that is i
can go all the way back to my original
equation which is uh g
minus v on 400 that's my acceleration
equals zero just go back to there
up the top there there it is g minus v
on 400 that's acceleration right so this
is very straightforward you can see why
it was only one mark
you can
add v on 400 to both sides and you'll
just get g and then v of course is equal
to 400 g
there's another way you could have done
this by the way if you just sort of cast
your eye back to this line here if you
say
like terminal velocity the idea is it's
the limit as t approaches infinity as
time progresses right that's what the
limiting velocity is equal to what do
you get out of this particular
expression on the right hand side well
this term here this term here has a
minus t on 400 there as t approaches
infinity
this whole number is going to get
enormous but negative which means that
this thing is going to go to 0 right so
therefore you end up with
400 g
times 1 minus 0 which unsurprisingly is
just the 400 g that we saw before either
of those were fine
it was a bit sad a number of students
returned to x double dot equals like you
know people use v dv on dx and which
dramatically increased the effort
required you could still get a valid
answer it was just really unnecessary
okay
final part of the paper if you can
believe we're almost there part three
how far has the object fallen after time
t how do we do this well like we saw
before we needed to um you need to do
integration to get um from
this sort of
acceleration equation here up into a
velocity equation and now i need to get
to displacement so i hope it's
reasonably
connecting in your brain that to go from
velocity to displacement i'm just going
to have to integrate again now i don't
have to integrate twice some students
did this as like a whole separate
question treat it as like well i better
go back to acceleration then off i go
but remember part one you've already
done one of the integrations you've
gotten from acceleration up to velocity
so let's use that right
i can say from
part one
i know that v is equal to let's just go
ahead and grab it here it is
this is my
velocity equation
with an extra orange arrow coming along
for the right and now to get to this
i can say or rather to use this i can
say well that velocity there is dx on dt
it's the change in displacement over
time so therefore it's just a
straightforward integration here right
there's a 400 g
which is a constant coefficient hanging
out the front and then you're going to
have t
because that's what your 1 integrates
into
and then just be careful here right you
are going to have a subtraction from the
original
um
term here
but then you need to divide by your
inside derivative you're doing a reverse
chain rule here right and your inside
function here is minus t on 400 so
you're dividing by minus one over four
hundred
dividing by minus one over four hundred
is the same as multiplying by minus four
hundred
so that's that integration done right
there and then close bracket um because
this is an indent definite integral
integration process i've got another
constant hanging around there which i'm
going to need to evaluate
let's tidy this up first so i get a 400g
t plus 400 there's my exponential term
and here is this secondary constant i
need to evaluate now same deal like we
said before right i need some kind of
initial condition here and there's an
initial condition that's implied but
it's not necessarily obvious to you
how far has the object fallen after time
t
how far is the object falling after time
t now let's just suppose we started from
like you know
1 000 meters in the air right well if we
fell
to 900
all i'm interested in is that is the gap
i started a thousand so i fell 100 now
i've i'm i'm at 900 right well if we
started at say two kilometers a year
2000 and then we fell 100 right we'd be
at 1900 but those absolute numbers don't
matter all that matters is the
difference between them so therefore i
could just set that original number um
as not one thousand two thousand i can
just set that to something convenient to
me if it's something convenient why
don't i just set it as
x equals zero then i will simplify all
my calculations and it will immediately
give me what that difference is because
there is no differential there's no
shift right so therefore i can say
consider
starting point as
x equals zero so we've talked about this
before as choosing a convenient origin
often the origin is like the ground
right but you can just as easily call
the origin some point in the air if
that's the starting point that's
meaningful to you okay if my starting
point is x equals 0 therefore i'm going
to substitute t equals 0 because that's
the initial condition so i get a 0 on
the left hand side i get a 400 g
and then in here i get 0 plus
400 and then e to the power of 0
is 1. so i'll just write a 1 there
plus my constant so hopefully you can
see that second constant is going to be
400 g
times 400 i could evaluate that but i'm
just going to leave it as that because
i'm about to substitute it back into
this expression up here and if the 400g
has already been factorized out well
i'll just leave it factorized out right
i can say therefore x is equal to
all of this stuff that we said before
zoop
i got an actual gravity on the way there
that's okay and then when i add i'm
going to add my constant right it's 400
g which i've already got here times 400
so there's going to be a 400 also
appearing
in the brackets
and that's it
so
well done if you got that far it was a
pretty tough paper overall and lots of
opportunities to really challenge
yourself but hopefully you learned
something as you went through these
questions